what was hard to get over was being
blamed for something that not only i
didn't do
but that happened to me meghan markle is
setting the record straight
telling oprah the real story behind the
infamous tabloid tale
that she made her sister-in-law kate
middleton cry
in 2018. the reverse happened megan says
during the preparation of her wedding to
prince harry
there was a confrontation between she
and kate over flower girl dresses
it made me cry and it really hurt my
feelings
and i thought in the context of
everything else that was going on
in those days leading to the wedding
that
it didn't make sense to not be just
doing whatever
what everyone else was doing which was
trying to be supportive knowing what was
going on with my dad and whatnot
megan went on to clarify that she didn't
tell the story to disparage kate
but to make a point that she didn't feel
protected by the royal institution
it was a really hard week of the wedding
and she was upset about something but
she owned it and she apologized and she
brought me flowers and
a note apologizing what was hard to get
over
was being blamed for something that not
only i didn't do
but that happened to me and and the
people who were part of our wedding
going to our comms team and saying
i know this didn't happen the duchess of
sussex also revealed
that she was always told to stay silent
a similar sentiment
royal expert katie nichol shared with
e.t
well there have been reports that megan
wasn't allowed to do this interview
two years ago and when she was certainly
being courted by
many high-profile members of the media
reports that gail king wanted to do a
sit-down and megan was told she wasn't
allowed to do that
i think we're going to hear much more
from megan in the oprah interview about
losing her voice and how she felt she
lost her voice when she was
a member of the royal family don't
forget she was forced to close
her instagram account um suddenly there
was
no shortage of people wanting an
interview but
out of the palace it was a clear no
megan also told oprah that she doesn't
have any negative feelings towards kate
i think it's really important for people
to understand the truth i i would hope
that she would have wanted that
corrected and maybe in the same way that
the
palace wouldn't let anybody else negate
it they wouldn't let her because she's a
good person
and i think so much of what i have seen
play out
is this idea of polarity where if you
love me you don't have to hate her
and if you love her you don't need to
hate me
you